well quick news alert for you the
associated press has
called the new york city democratic
mayoral primary which is effectively the
same as the mayor's race given it's a
one-party state in new york and it looks
like brooklyn borough president eric
adams is very likely to be the next
mayor of new york
we are absolutely certain we will be
deeply disappointed by eric adams
everybody says eric adams has all kinds
of problems we agree with him on
anything
but the point of eric adams is worth
remembering
he won because he was alone in
acknowledging that violent crime
is a huge problem for everyone in new
york and he vowed to do something about
it
that is a winning message because it's
rooted in physical reality
and we wish him absolutely the best in
fighting crime in new york it's the key
to saving that city
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else